welcome to this video playing confuse
our confuso turkey let's see what we
what we got okay maybe a Queen's Indian
or Hedgehog okay see 5 or Bishop e7 okay
we get to get 22 and hedgehogs type of
position I'm head on the clock UPI a
jack check out this line of the slime
that I'm playing it is a very modest one
but it always gives white um I'm a
pleasant very nagging little advantage
um actually take them I wonder maybe
maybe there is not a 4 but probably this
even be five against that so I should
probably take night cakes okay i guess
the trade
hmm that's quite quite surprising isn't
this just a just better for wide I mean
not by by uture not not not very very
not very much but it's definitely better
for white Bishop g4 maybe this Bishop c5
look-see one Bishop c5 a3 a4 whom
probably not leading to that much Bishop
Bishop for bishops if Bishop g4 Bishop
c5 hmm if I'm hmm yeah that's not so
easy to determine what is the best
continuation here even look see one
Bishop c5 Bishop d4 so something takes
takes I mean waiting with the rook it's
quite that's quite very simple black I'm
not sure what's best here interesting b5
Roxy one is fantastic for white of
course so Bishop c5 is definitely the
only move I can also play rook d one
after that rock the eight
look the one look 28 takes takes before
maybe hmm difficult also be four might
be an idea before takes bishop b6 rook
the Sun will be one and then back
difficult I can also how to hard to
evaluate what is best here I thought
beef if the coming if for one net
doesn't let miss something I had said
sets really too little okay I didn't I
plated up Jackie Bradley and I played it
badly definitely check not sure about
this check King now covers the e2 and I
have rocked his six coming i might play
rook e1 hmm and looked his successor not
a good idea
I don't have time to to figure this out
really my active king should count for
something rook age one okay let's let's
just start to grab things here I
definitely want one some material and
then support the be porn or whatever my
passer is with the king
tags tags that's probably probably not
working but I can go here now the loop
trade is definitely losing so grab here
and you must take here then King c5 time
money or f5 intending the rook check
this is also quite good a 5 SB 5 check
check first
let me improve this a bit okay maybe now
FF FF the the beep artists is very
dangerous quite clearly shown this winch
on this win the game I mean the beep on
supported by my king his King on the
eighth-ranked that should win right now
that said to win the beep on the B part
will promote there is nothing he can do
really check check check I've rook c7
check-check
here's some trying because my time is a
bit is shut down but i will get response
now Jeff checkmate yeah now in this end
game was it was difficult around here
it's quite clear that the resulting end
game should be very substantially better
for me but I wasn't sure how to do it
there was there was no many
possibilities Bishop divorce one of them
and here here I'm not not sure I'd of
the many ideas but I wasn't sure what to
do look see one I mentioned this maybe
this is the best this is the computer
line takes takes and now the big point
is that i have this I have the C file
and I will invade with the rook it is a
gap that is substantially better for
what I guess what I did is sum is less
convincing something like that will
happen I will probably win one of those
pawns due to the activity it's not of
not like like a quick and easy win but
it is very good for me this was my
alternative but I guess this is less
convincing I can still go back to Luke
see one ya hear King evade immediately
what also possible here I also route d3
ok 3 is also a good idea so this this
and then maybe also bring the king over
yeah this is a check of course still
wide is better here but it's not a check
super convincing thing rook da droog a
idea this was an alternative okay I'm
here how much better is it for white
it's not so not so easy if the same
not sure this is a clear way for black
to hold this it can definitely get ugly
very very quickly the computers main
line is king of seven there's probably
some way would like to just lose them to
at the end yeah but this when I have
they porn or something extra at the end
my king is always supporting it I don't
know if black can hell with this really
the computers just on 0.54 white but
maybe a matter of calculation depth the
way it went I mean it very quickly
turned into it into ugly business rookie
6 is not helping of course it took them
and fif air this is this is an important
little thing to make sure that the black
king is not escaping we want this huge
advantage in space check just just
support the point and then I want longer
I want to get to this spawn of course
this also possibly kinky sex him he went
a five and this is probably losing a b5
is a direct win according to the engine
and this was my suspicions but something
like this is not not much fun of course
but am i winning not clear something
like this
yeah that what the White has such a huge
advantage in space the king there should
be there should be a winner really not
sure yet how really on the other end hmm
don't really see how I how I actually
win the spawn
I'm not sure I don't see a winning plan
maybe some some of the u.s. can can come
up with some way I don't see well in
plain white looks fantastic but maybe
there is a snow in relates happens after
that the big bonus is challenged widest
just pushing this through okay thanks
for watching